Hi, I'm "Ian Lake"
I strongly believe that adding features with AppCompat
It is what moves your application from good to wonderful.
AppCompat uses the portal style in Lollipop
You can advertise a range of colors in your theme
Which automatically changes the number of elements in your user interface.
There are three main colors - colorPrimary and colorPrimaryDark
And colorAccent.
colorPrimary is where the beginning, and acts as a color marker
Master in all your application.
If you are using a standard AppCompat theme,
You will find the application bar uses colorPrimary in its basic settings.
If you are using a toolbar, adjust the color
Using the colorPrimary background property.
colorPrimaryDark can be used only in hardware
Running Android 5.0 or higher, for background color services
For the status bar, it must as the name implies
The shadow is darker than your primary color.
colorAccent slightly different,
It affects a large number of elements
In your application.
You will notice this in the EditText focus, the bottom line and the cursor.
CheckBoxes, as well as background color,
Button and floating procedure.
The differences between each of your primary colors are very important
The background colors remain so clear.
There are a few other colors less commonly used,
But it can be really helpful.
ColorControlNormal adjusts the natural state of the components,
Such as EditText not selected.
ColorControlActivated colorAccent is disabled as in the case of items
Active or selected such as CheckBoxes.
And colorControlHighlight which adjusts the multiplier coloring.
Too many customizations are available without touching
Any of the individual components.
But the addition of these powerful features is not limited only
On the whole activity.
You can also apply the theme to any scene in your application used
Android: theme, which allows you to change
This scene and his sons only.
To make this easy, there is the ThemeOverlay principle.
ThemeOverlay is not like the full thread,
Just seek to change the few things they need,
This will be appropriate to change the elements
In a normally light theme to display in a dark background,
Assume that the application bar has a bold primary color,
While building a custom theme color,
Make sure your theme is ThemeOverlay.AppCompat.
This confirms that elements like colorAccent
Works correctly on both Lollipop and Lollipop devices
Topics and ThemeOverlays can be a powerful way
To change the shape of your application, whether in activity or on a level
watching.
Another tool to help you build better apps.
[Music]